[Music]
foreign
the Press preview our first look at
what's on the front pages as they arrive
so it's time to see what's making the
headlines with the daily mirrors
associate editor Kevin McGuire and the
telegraph Deputy comment editor
Annabelle Denham so a very good evening
to both of you nice to see you both
um please say that you will both be with
us uh from now until just before
midnight but before we chat to them
let's take a look at what's making at
the front pages of tomorrow's papers and
the I says that Boris Johnson is in
Peril after angry clashes with the party
gate inquiry
the Metro seems to think it didn't go
well for the former prime minister their
headline Boris the backlash
is the Guardians take flimsy partygate
answers leave Johnson on the brink
the telegraph describes him as besieged
but defiant
the star Compares him to little
Britain's Vicky Pollard and her yeba
Nobert catchphrase
in the mail our press preview colleague
Sarah Vine argues that whether your view
of Mr Johnson is positive or negative no
one's mind has been changed today
well the express offers his defense hand
on heart I did not lie to the house
whilst the son foregoes any mention of
Boris Johnson on its front page and
instead leads with Prince William's
visit to Poland to meet British and
polish troops there
and in other news the Ft has word of a
quarter point rise in U.S interest rates
and just a reminder that by scanning the
QR code that you can see on screen
during the program you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's papers for
yourself while you watch us
right now let's bring in Kevin McGuire
and Annabelle denim to go through some
of those front pages a very good evening
to both of you and perhaps inevitably
the front page is dominated by Boris
Johnson's appearance before the
Privileges committee today this is their
investigation of course into whether he
deliberately or recklessly misled
Parliament uh over parties in Downing
Street he says he's admitted that the
house was misled but he believed what he
said at the time he says so let's take a
look at the paper's coverage Kevin how
convincing do the papers think that he
was let's start with the eye
yeah I would say I'd say across the
board uh not very uh not very convincing
and of course there the eye having uh
Johnson Johnson in Peril
um pointing out he was muttering
complete nonsense at times with some of
the some of the uh the questions but the
the members of the committee including
conservative MPS four of uh the seven
MPS are concerned particularly Bernard
Jenkin uh did not seem to accept his his
explanations I thought he was pretty uh
unconvincing actually in it through I
wasn't a fan of his before but he has
been a grease piglet that's wriggled
free many times but I think this time
he's on the spit
well yeah and let's take a look at the
Metro there's a whole load of papers
that have got on the front page
Annabelle the Metro Boris the backlash
they talk about him being rattled in
those little sub heads there they say
that he snapped you don't know what
you're saying at one point they say he
squirmed over slogans and bottles of
booze so they're saying there that he
was pretty uncomfortable at moments but
was there a Smoking Gun was there a
moment where the committee would say
this is enough for us to go for our
nuclear option if you like of a large
suspension of him from the House of
Commons
I really have my doubts I don't think
there were any bombshell uh Revelations
No Smoking Gun as you say um Can the
community be very confident that he lied
I'm not sure that they can confident
enough let's not to forget I forget that
to suspend him and potentially uh force
him out I think actually the Metro
started up quite nicely saying that he
squirmed he certainly did but he's a
Survivor and he'll fight on
um I think you know I don't know how
many of his Nine Lives he's managed to
uh get through but perhaps he's got um
just one more left so as much as we're
reading about his future potentially
being uh in Jeopardy I think Boris could
Bluster on um throughout his political
career he's managed to almost surround
himself with this cloud of confusion
that's enabled him to often claim
plausible done eye ability and I'm not
sure this is any exception
let's bring in your paper Kevin which
I've just had to put in front of me I
think it's just dropped in
um the headline there in the mirror just
drinks after a difficult day question
mark plenty of people were having
difficult days Boris and that refers to
his defense that uh he believed that
rules weren't broken that it was
reasonable of him to rely on the
insurances of his advisors and all also
that any Gatherings that did go on were
necessary and essential to government
yeah because that because that flimsy
reference um earlier it was uh Harriet
Harman saying yeah you had flimsy
assurances it was within uh within the
rules and guidance who told you that uh
apart from trying to put a couple of uh
press people under the bus he he
wouldn't say because I thought the key
moment actually was Bernard Jenkins uh
saying you can't have leaving those
thank you parties he was calling them
Boris as well yes you can and I think
that was the key moment I think it's
that is why the committee will find him
uh guilty I believe of recklessly
misleading Parliament because he didn't
use his own eyes as Harriet Harman
others put it and saw what was happening
the new you know he is the person who
brought in the rules and the guidelines
he knew what was happening around the
country people getting out of funerals
gonna say goodbye to loved ones and he
thinks it's okay to have what were
parties and they it's what an irony that
is Vanity photographer hired at
taxpayers expense as effectively dropped
him in it with some of those uh some of
those pictures so yeah people people
knew you couldn't have part you couldn't
have leaving parties and these kind of
say well yes you could because we've got
to raise morale and I think that will
just not go down well with that
committee what the punishment they
decide is another matter and about maybe
right he escapes it may not press the
nuclear button and suspending for 10
days which could trigger the by-election
in Uxbridge but I think it's watching
today and listening to hearing listening
to their questions I think it's pretty
difficult to see how they will not reach
the conclusion that he was at the very
least Reckless and and you you use that
word flimsy the quote from Harriet
Harman that's on the guardian's front
page isn't it flimsy partygate answers
leave Johnson on the brink however a
more positive headline in your newspaper
Annabelle the Daily Telegraph Johnson
besieged but defiant and does that in
some ways kind of reflect how the public
might feel about this that perhaps a
predictable line taken from the papers
you'd think the telegraph might be more
sympathetic towards Boris Johnson he
wrote for the paper for years after all
do you think the public as well has an
idea of what they think of Boris Johnson
already and this appearance won't change
that
I think that's you know that's
absolutely right so what's quite
interesting that's pulled out uh on the
front page of the telegraph is this idea
that Boris might refuse the outcome
um of this inquiry
um I think that's one of the really
fascinating things about this
parliamentary trial It Whatever the
verdict actually the bigger question
arguably is whether he publicly accepts
it or whether he opts for this line that
he urged on making today that its
conclusions were always going to be
biased and we heard that for a few days
in the run-up
um of course
um the tweets a couple of years ago from
Harriet Harman calling him a liar sort
of uh resurfaced of course there was the
moving of the goal posts um in terms of
um whether he deliberately or recklessly
misled Parliament and that's led to all
sorts of accusations and skepticism that
this might be a kangaroo court now Boris
Johnson uh stopped short of saying that
um himself but nonetheless in his
opening statement made very clear that
he feared the committee had already made
up his mind and I think he certainly
wants uh Tory MPS not necessarily those
who are grilling him but his back
benches to view this inquiry is some
sort of kangaroo court so when we get uh
it's finding its conclusions in the next
few weeks I think it will be very
interesting you to see how Boris Johnson
responds to that and you know Kevin's
absolutely right I was as outraged as
anybody by uh partygate the fact that
here we all were adhering to very strict
controls on where we could go and who we
could see and what we could do and yet
civil servants those working in number
10 the Prime Minister seem to be having
all these Jolly Old knees up
um but what concerns me actually is that
this is what we're talking about now
rather that and of course tomorrow being
the three year anniversary of the first
lockdown
um the impact that it had on all of our
lives and still continues to have the
economic uh impact the impact on schools
with a lot of peoples who were absent
during the pandemic not returning and it
frustrates me that we're not talking
about those issues more and are instead
talking about you know Boris Johnson and
partygate well yes and let's just show
one more um front page that covers this
this is the Daily Express Boris hand on
heart I did not lie to the house talking
about him being bullish
um in his defense today and picking up
on that point about that Annabelle said
this this did happen years ago some
people might say why are we still
talking about
um what happened in lockdown in in
Downing Street years later I mean how
important is this inquiry not only to
establish what Boris Johnson's Behavior
was but also just to to ensure that
Parliament is smooth running that it
does have checks and balances in place
yeah look at the the express they're
loyal to the very end
um but if he had his hand on his heart
he didn't lie it was probably the first
time he hasn't lied in my view but uh
like uh Annabelle's paper thought it was
worth putting all my Hancock's uh
WhatsApp messages in well not all of
them some of them had fizzled out after
a while uh and I thought quite right
because you learned something and I
think if you have a prime minister who
was the rulemaker was the rule breaker
and he wasn't following his own rules
when other people did and then he lied
about it but it was broken by the mirror
uh and initially I think I think that is
an issue and it's partly been done now
and not a while back because he has also
dragged these feet and he hasn't wanted
The Inquirer to go ahead uh really
speedily all those other issues we just
got we do disgusting economic impact we
discuss kids we discuss uh what happened
in Care Homes PPE scandals the VIP lanes
and the rip-offs all that is discussed
but I think or there is time to discuss
whether a prime minister that
deliberately misled the House of Commons
MPS I think in a democracy and
accountability of scrutiny I think
that's important and that's why he's
there and bizarrely if when he was
caught out he should have had the
parties in the first place he has the
parties if when the mirror broke the
story he'd put up his hand he said look
we've made mistakes we'll look into it
uh we'll apologize he might still be
prime minister but he didn't he did what
he always does and that becomes
incredibly Breeze and tries to change
the subject and then doesn't tell the
truth and so he is actually the
architect of his own downforge why he's
no longer prime minister
let's just quickly show The Daily Mail
they have a servine article on their
front page
um questioning whether any Minds would
change after this what she calls a pure
box office
um
evidence giving but let's take a look at
the Daily Star as well they have a bit
of fun with it as the Daily Star is what
to do
um yeah but no but uh is that's quite an
old reference isn't it Vicky Pollard I
mean obviously I remember it because
I've been around for years but anyway
and uh Pinocchio nose there on the front
of the Daily Star I mean just to wrap up
talking about Boris Johnson Annabelle
what do you think his future is now
I I suspect that he'll limp on at least
until the next general election let's
not let's not forget the few weeks we
were talking about whether he might do a
chicken run might be parachuted into a
safer seed but no it's been confirmed
that he's going to stand again in
Oxbridge where he's got a pretty slim
majority so whether or not
um he's held to account by uh his voters
in 18 months two years time you know
remains to be seen but I think it's
entirely possible that he will find
himself out for job in 2025
um but no pretty a grotesque image on
the cover of the star there um comparing
Boris Johnson to Vicki Pollard and it
certainly did feel like that at times
this afternoon watching his three-hour
uh grilling from the Privileges uh
committee I've actually never watched
Little Britain but I was familiar with
the um catchphrase and uh no they're
certainly not concealing how they view
this but let let's see whether Boris
Johnson lives to fight on another few
weeks
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me tonight Kevin McGuire
and Annabelle Denham so welcome back
let's get stuck into so many big stories
around today
um stories like in the Metro here the
fact that um Richie sunax and Northern
Ireland brexit deal has has passed
through Parliament might have been all
over the front pages on another day
Annabelle and how important was this to
Rishi sunak the fact that only 29 people
voted against 22 of them tories
oh I think this is very a very
significant moment for Rishi sunax uh
Premiership perhaps the one actually
that establishes them as a better prime
minister than he ever was Chancellor in
recent days speculation had grown that
CNAC would have a rebellion potentially
a significant Rebellion on his hands
um the dep came out against it then the
European research group uh Liz truss
pretty Patel uh Jacob Reese Morgan
momentum really appeared to be building
you had three uh former Party leaders
who were opposed to it um and the
question really at that point was would
soon act have to rely on labor votes in
order to get this deal through and what
would that mean for his Premiership
um you know I think there are concerns
that in trying so hard not to be Boris
Johnson he was at risk of becoming uh
Theresa May and completely ineffectual
and actually that's today's vote has put
paid to a lot of those concerns and I
think will allow him
um to perhaps move away from the
accusations that he's just a technocrat
and towards somebody who can pursue a
real agenda in the time that he's got
left and yet Kevin dup amongst those who
voted against they say they won't go
back to stormwatch which has been
suspended for so long now I mean I mean
how much we blow is that that they can't
get power showing back up and running
yeah of course I don't want to go back
to Stormont they're looking for an
excuse not to go back to Stormont
because they would have to accept uh
Shin Fein first Minister first time
Michelle O'Neill so they're desperate to
void that so they'll have to be fresh
elections
and if they if they lose anything win
again then
I'm not quite sure how that impasse will
be broken but I thought but during Boris
Johnson's um appearance today this was
the most significant moment to show he's
a busted flush because he's voted
against it along with his trust 22 Tory
MPS his following is gone
yeah interesting interesting to see how
that's interpreted a quick look at
another story that came out today
um Annabelle
um Richie soon like published a summary
of His tax return
um not the full details but we got a
pretty good idea of um well how wealthy
he is frankly
yes I mean that's the rightly page uh
430 000 pounds in tax in the 21 22
Financial year
um he's earned 4 million pounds in the
last uh three years these are vast uh
money I think it was last year that he
was that became the first prime minister
to be placed on the Sunday Times rich
list and around position 220 uh I think
you know no nobody now can possibly be
in the dot the fact that Rishi sunak is
a very wealthy uh man um what concerns
me is that this has led to some
questions over whether he's
um over his appropriateness and fitness
to be running our country how in touch
can he be with the difficulties that a
lot of people are facing during a cost
of living crisis um but I I you know I I
don't think we should pay you know too
much attention to that and we should
judge him not on how wealthy is but
rather whether he's able to uh get
inflation down and
um get GDP perhaps growing um that that
means to me is what we should be judging
him on we've only got 30 seconds covered
but I just want to show the front page
of the sun partly because there's no
Boris Johnson anywhere on the front of
it instead they lead uh with the Prince
of Wales visiting troops in Poland yes I
think that could be because they're
definitely a James slack uh worked in
Downing Street and was almost certainly
got a fixed penalty notice because his
was one of the two leaving parties on
the eve of the Duke of edinburgh's uh
funeral when the queen was seen sitting
low yeah since apologize for that but I
suspect that may have played a role in
the sun selection of stories that
Johnson's been done for parties they've
got a debt yeah who I think was was fine
too
and interesting in itself the fact that
he did visit troops of course and
something that I'm sure we'll we'll talk
about
um in the next hour or so but for the
moment we are out of time you will be
back uh with me again at 11 to talk
through the top stories but Annabelle
and Kevin for the moment thanks both
very much indeed